hi everyone this is the num PI approach
we're at PI data San Francisco it's
Saturday August 13 2016 so as I was
saying before the talk started I just
wanted to let you know this is I give a
lot of talks at different PI data events
and usually the talks I give are very
advanced talks about C Python hacking or
crazy things you can do with Python this
is a departure from that this is a
novice level tutorial design exercise in
how to use numpy this talk was born out
of some discussions I had with people
who are software engineers had a lot of
experience writing code in C++ in Java
and Python who had never before really
used matlab or r or used numpy and
needed some understandings a better
understanding of the approaches that we
take the vectorized approach that we
take the Fortran 90 style approach that
we take when writing code in number so
what I decided to do was put together a
small presentation in order to show as a
design exercise the way that somebody
who really only knows pure python would
write this and somebody knows pure
python very well would write something
and then how somebody a not completely
naive and also not incredibly
sophisticated but a middle-of-the-road
program are familiar with numpy how they
would write the same code and to
highlight some of the differences in
some of the differences in that approach
so let's get started so we can start
real simple if we're doing anything with
any with vector manipulation or matrix
manipulation we could define a function
called dot and impure Python we might
write dot like this we're dotting a
vector U and a vector V and we just end
up multiplying all the components of U
and V and summing that and you can see
if we create two vectors of numbers
randomly chosen from
and I get the result and so another
example if I have a FB here i can
multiply these two matrices and the
result is and the result is what you
have here and you can see everything
here is written in pure python there's
no use of any of the data science
libraries that we're familiar with very
simple code and something that somebody
who had familiarity with pure python
might use as their approach this is the
approach that I found that people who
have a lot of experience writing C++ or
C use where they're expect to be able to
manipulate vectors just using the
built-in see arrays and so they say well
python has lists and lists are just see
Ras but better so I'll do the same kind
of manipulations using those but there's
a reason we don't do that and the most
immediate reason that we don't do that
is if I have a and B as these two lists
of lists representing matrices and I
multiply them together with my naive
Python Matt mall it takes 14 point two
seconds to do and if I do the same thing
using numpy it takes 164 milliseconds so
we can see immediately that there's an
order of magnitude or even two orders of
magnitude difference in these two
approaches and that's oftentimes our
very first intuition as to there might
be a better way out there so with that
said i want to show you an example of
any design exercise that you that I went
through writing code in a very pure
fluent pythonic style and then rewriting
that in a numpy style and highlighting
some of the differences so to make this
a little bit more interesting than
something as synthetic is what we looked
at before you know we start by just
considering a very simple definition of
or rather a fairly simple problem
statement for a genetic algorithm and
the problem statement looks like this we
want to implement a binary genetic
algorithm with Fitness proportional
selection one point crossover bit flip
mutation the chromosomes are are going
to be some structure that have either
zero or one's the fitness of that
chromosome is the number of ones in the
chromosome the optimal solution is then
a bit string or a chromosome that has
only one values and we want to simulate
this for very
population sizes and various chromosome
lengths and graph it so that's our
that's our requirement so let's think
how it is so I disparagingly I like to
call the style of Python that I'm about
to write here stick up your butt Python
because I know we've all worked with
people who are really really hardcore
Python programmers and they are very
nitpicky about style and best practice
and pep a door flake eight or who knows
what and very quickly about oh you
should use a generator here rather than
something else and they may be labor
some of what we consider to be or what
we what we broadly call Python code they
may be labor that notion more so than
the rest of us who are a little bit more
focused or for whom maybe code quality
doesn't matter as much as time to
delivery so what they might say is we
need to represent a random chromosome in
order to the simulation so what we'll
have is a generator expression that
randomly chooses zeros and ones
infinitely so here this random
chromosome is some function that gives
you a chromosome of infinite length
because in a pure pythonic style why
would you ever define the length of the
chromosome that you need you want to use
an iterable and then use tools like I
slice in order to chop that up and so in
order to get the random population what
you do is you just take your infinitely
large random chromosome you slice it to
the length that you want and then you
generate a population you can see this
random population is also a potentially
infinite random population because that
would be I would say a more pure
pythonic style where instead of fixing
the size of these structures you use
tools like itertools in order to in
order to put that functionality in the
hands of the users of these functions
rather than specifying them yourself
I've given a lot of talks about
generators and why this is a good
approach to use is covered in those
talks it's mostly about eliminating
modalities in the code and allowing some
of the functionality you want namely
choosing the size of the population or
choosing the sign of the chromosome to
be firmly in the hands of the person
who's calling the code rather than in
the hands of the person who writes the
code additionally there are some
performance benefits namely around
memory usage or lease around being able
to control memory usage that said we can
see this put into use so we need to
construct various populations
so for our simulation will look at
populations of size 5 10 20 and 50 and
that's the size of the chromosome itself
so five zeros or ones 1000 ones 2000
ones 5000 ones and will store this as a
dictionary that's the most reasonable
Python type for us to use where we map
the length to the population you can see
each population is of size 10 so here's
all of our populations you can see the
fitness of this population is somewhere
in the middle this chromosome here has
very good fitness this chromosome here
has the worst possible fitness and what
we should see what our genetic algorithm
is we should converge towards this kind
of perfect fitness of all ones so the
next thing we might want to do is figure
out what the fitness is so the fitness
of this chromosome could just be
represented as just a simple average we
sum all the ones in the chromosome again
it's just a list of Python integer zeros
or one values and we divide by the
length and so if i take the fitness of
one of the chromosomes of my population
i get point six this Fitness will be
tied into the probability of mating so
the fitter chromosomes have a higher
probability of then going on to mate and
create similarly fit chromosomes so you
can see we're trying to generate a
probability from 0 to 1 of this
chromosome being chosen as one of the
potential pairs in a mating and so you
can see here we can calculate all the
fitnesses of our population so we want
to figure out what the probabilities of
the population are now we want to scale
these so what we'll do is here since
even though we do we we want to figure
out what the relative probability of any
one chromosome being picked out of this
selection so we'll do is we'll calculate
the fitness for every chromosome and
then we'll scale that by the total
fitness and so that will give us a
scaled weighting of which is the most
likely chromosome to pick based on this
fitness and you can see we're using a
list comprehension for this structure
we're returning a generator expression
because there's no need to materialize
this data unless it's until it's
actually used and when we call this on
our data we can see here are the
probabilities these two chromosomes are
more likely to mate than these two which
have lower fitness next we need to
figure out so this is actually where it
gets very tricky we have to compute a
weighted choice because we need to go
through all of our chromosomes and with
some waiting ran
we choose two of those unfortunately in
the Python random module random that
choice has no way to provide weightings
for you so we have to go through what is
somewhat of a labored exercise that
indicates to us that authors behind the
Python random module may not have
considered all of the statistical uses
of the random module and so certain
functions that you might expect to be
available like being able to randomly
chose choose from a non-uniform
distribution of a set of categorical
values is not available so we end up
having to write that ourselves and we
try very hard to write this and as pure
a Python fashion as we can using you
know fancy things like list slicing and
you know making sure that we zip things
together given that which admittedly is
a little ugly and maybe there might be a
way to improve it we can then write
select which takes a population and
selects all of the mates for our
population what we do is we calculate
all the probabilities and then
infinitely we just pick two two
chromosomes and those are the pairs and
we yield those so here we have another
infinite iterator that gives us pairings
of mates selected by their probability
and so you can see what we can do is we
can use weighted choice to randomly
choose which of these two pick and you
can see if we have we give the weighted
choices a function that gives that takes
the categories the elements that you're
choosing from and also the probabilities
here so in this case you can see B D or
E or the only ones that will be chosen a
and C whatever be chosen what we can see
if we call select we can pull out one
element from this population and we can
see these are the two pairs that were
chosen based on their probability to
mate once we have that we need to
implement one kind of mutation so the
mutation that we need to have here is
single bit flip mutation our single bit
flip mutation just works by randomly to
tiding one index and then flipping the
value of that index now one one thing
that we're going to do here is we're not
going to flip it in place we're going to
do a copy so that we don't mutate the
original data we just return a new
chromosome with that one bit flipped and
so here you can see we have one
selection of a chromosome from our pop
relation and then we did a random bit
flip and you can see this bit here is
what got flipped once we do that we need
to implement crossover so for crossover
what we'll do is we'll randomly select
if it's the mother and the father this
way or the father and the mother this
way we randomly select a position and
then we take the chromosome up to that
position or the mother up to that
position and append the father up to
that position or from that position on
words or the other way around so very
simple crossover in a pure pythonic
style and so you can see if we randomly
select two mates from our population
here here and we cross them over this is
the result of hybridizing these two
chromosomes and we get something that in
this case happens to be more fit than
more fit that one of the parents and
only as fit as the other parent lastly
we need to have some mechanism in order
to actually do the simulation we need to
be able to breed these chromosomes so we
take a list of mates we take a mutation
rate because we're not going to mutate
every chromosome will only mutate
according to some user-defined rate so
we'll determine will we'll do a little
bit of trick with the with the choice
function in the random module in order
to determine in order to determine
whether or not a chromosome will mutate
and then what we do is we just say for
each of the parents in the mates we were
provided we create the child by crossing
over those two parents we are doing this
again in a very pure pythonic style so
we're going to use functionality like
iterable unpacking and then we'll try to
mutate that child and will give that
child a couple of different
possibilities to mutate so will allow
the child to mutate one time for every
bit in the chromosome so for the 24 the
chromosomes that are 20 bits in length
will give them 20 choices to mutate for
the ones that are five bits in length
the book about five choice to mutate now
I know some of you in the audience may
be very familiar with evolutionary
algorithms with genetic programming and
I'll say remember this is a very very
simple application from essentially what
you might find at the back of a textbook
for an introductory book just in order
to make the design interesting but
out be laboring some of the top some of
the domain specific content so here you
can see we have our population we select
our mates and so we're going to select
five mates and so these are the mates
that are selected these will be bred
when we breed them this is the result of
the population so those original five or
those original five chromosomes breed to
create this new generation once we have
that we're done we need to put this into
some some top-level simulation code so
we'll determine the number of steps that
we're going to run our simulation for
the population size for each of the
populations these sizes of each of the
chromosomes so we'll look at 5 10 20 and
50 bits in length and then we just need
to run this in a loop taking the
previous population breeding at creating
the new population and so on so we run
this in a loop we can see we create the
new population for each run then we just
made that population and append it now
we want to collect all the information
about all the populations you want to
have a snapshot in time of how that
population evolves so we don't want to
throw away any old data so what the
resulting structure will look like is a
dictionary keyed on the length of the
chromosome with the list where the index
of that list is which step in my
simulation from step 02 step 99 by each
of the different runs so we'll actually
potentially do this in multiple runs and
so when we take that and we graph it we
see something looks like this now by the
way this simulation ends up taking 2.6
seconds for populations of a size 100
for 100 steps each for our for
chromosome sizes and we graph it we get
something that looks pretty reasonable
we can see this is graphing the fitness
over time so at step zero most of the
fitness is are around point five which
is what we'd expect since these
chromosomes were randomly generated so
there's a equal probability of having a
0 or a 1 and over time they converge to
perfect fitness and what we can see is
for the bit sizes the smaller the bit
size the faster it converges the perfect
fitness that's what we'd expect because
you know there's fewer areas for
mutations so these are the exact results
that we want you can see for the bit
size of 20 it takes a fairly long
time for it to converge to better
fitness so that's our exercise and
that's an approach that I would expect
somebody with familiarity with Python
but no familiarity with MATLAB or are or
numpy would write this code and they'd
actually be very proud of themselves in
writing this code but there are a couple
of things that are missing number one
and I won't say that I don't want to
disparage the person who would design in
this fashion but I want to point out
some limitations number one the use of
Python lists to represent vector data is
a bad idea Python lists are strictly
collection types and they only really
represent collections of data they don't
represent matrices and they're not very
good at representing vectors one clear
indication of that is in the very first
example that I showed you it was
actually pretty ugly syntax to multiply
those two matrices whereas with numpy
and Python 35 we have our nice map mall
operator and so the syntax is at least
much nicer we can we can do element wise
operations and numpy much easier than we
can code lists even using things like
list comprehensions in Python
additionally it's not very fast for
these explicit Python loops these
explicit Python loops are loops which
the Python interpreter has to interpret
itself there is a lot of overhead for
function calls in Python and so having a
lot of Python function calls in a tight
loop doesn't give us very good
performance and this is necessary
because the Python list has no provides
us with no guarantees as to the
interrelate as to the contents of that
list or the interrelations between the
contents of that list so for example a
Python list can be completely
heterogeneous you have no guarantee that
it's set to a specific data type so you
can't specialize in operation being
performed or being broadcasted across a
list in any fashion because you have no
idea what the types contain lists are
until you see them and additionally you
have no guarantees about the
interrelations between the types because
a Python list can contain rich pie
objects those pie objects could have
interrelations so you could have some
operation called on one of the pie
objects in that list that then mutates
another pie optic net list so there's no
way to automatically parallel eyes that
there's no way to reduce the complexity
of what you have to compute in order to
do
aggregate operation and a Python list
and that's one of the core reasons why
we're going to redesign this a numpy the
numpy and dra is a data type that
restricts us in some severe ways number
one it restricts us by requiring that we
think in terms of machine types
operations on Python integers are
actually reasonably fast but they aren't
necessarily specialized to machine
operations because Python integers
support arbitrary precision and size
it's possible that you can have integers
of some arbitrary size what was
originally called in Python to you know
the long object and there's no way for
you to say specifically that an
operation being performed on a Python
list is only going to use specific
assembly instructions because the
contents are only 32-bit or 64-bit
integers numpy think requires you to
think in terms of machine types and so
when you look at the d-type of a numpy
array it might say int or it might say
float but it's being it's saying int
because it's using the default size of
integer on your machine internally it
really is specialized to a 32-bit
integer or 60 16 bit integer or 64-bit
integer similarly the float type is
specialized to that the reason for that
is when you perform element wise
computations on a numpy ndarray the
numpy internals want to actually perform
those computations as efficiently as
possible given the machine knowledge of
those types so for example if you have
64-bit integers on a 64-bit machine it
wants to use single assembly
instructions in order to add them or
multiply them rather than having to
perform dispatch at that step
additionally one way that we we can see
is the number the pure python approach
is really one of trying to build this
simulation in terms of small completely
independent elements such as you breed
one population and that's one operation
and you call that in the loop and that
forms another operation and creating
those building blocks in that fashion
when we rebuild this with numpy we'll
see that because numpy is a tool for n
dimensional arrays we have this almost a
dimensionality trick or we can take what
in Python would be explicit looping and
then
that an umpire one more dimension on our
matrix which is then performed as a very
efficient is then performed as part of a
very efficient element-wise operation so
let me show how we let me show you how
you we do this in numpy and i'll repeat
my disclaimer from the beginning this is
where as the first approach was very
nitpicky python this approach is not
very nitpicky numpy there's probably
some areas where i could write this dump
i even better it's not a completely
naive numpy approach and you'll see that
in one or two places where i do
something that you might not have
expected so we'll start with the most
basic we want to represent the
chromosome and so you know numpy gives
us machine types the bool is numb pious
representation of something that's
either 0 or 1 internally it's probably
going to represent this as whatever the
machine size int is because representing
the bit flags probably isn't that
efficient since doing operations doing
brought doing element wise operations on
bit flags I don't know that you can do
that faster than you could do it on
blocks of memory that's a fixed size so
you can see we're going to use parts of
the numpy random module will generate
the entire chromosome at once one thing
that's different here is in our Python
approach we had our building block was
generate an individual value for this
chromosome and then loop to create the
entire chromosome the numpy approach is
immediately removing that one layer of
looping that one layer of nesting where
our numpy random function allows us to
give it the size of what we want to
generate and all of that looping is
happening internal to numpy where the
numpy code has certain assurances that
it doesn't have to do dynamic dispatch
that it doesn't have to know too much
information about or that it doesn't
have additional requirements on the
information that it has to have in order
to perform that computation and so it
can perform this much more efficiently
our fitness function is just numpy don't
mean it's as easy as that and so we can
calculate the fitness of our chromosome
in order to calculate our population
that's pretty easy to do we just
randomly generate instead of using the
code for geranium during a single
chromosome we actually rewrite that same
code to generate a random population
because a random population is not
generate a random chromosome
loop and collect those it's just
generate a numpy ndarray of one greater
dimension and you can see the rows of
this represent each chromosome sorry the
rows represent each chromosome and the
columns represent each of the bits of a
chromosome if we want to generate the
probabilities again the code is much
simpler we just take the mean across an
axis so previously in the code we had to
do an explicit looping here we can just
use the axis mechanisms and numpy to
perform the mean just across the rows
and then divide those with an element
wise computation by the sum of all the
fitnesses and so you can see here are
all of the fitnesses of all of the
chromosomes in my tent in my population
of 10 chromosomes in order to choose two
mates what we could do is we could just
create numpy arrays with the indices and
do an MP choice we could choose from
those and we could see this says pair
chromosome 2 with chromosome 1 and we
could do that with let's see if we can
get this off to the side we can do that
we can pat we can pass MP dot choice of
size parameter so we can actually select
all the mates as a single building block
numpy operation all at once so here we
have a chromosome and we want to do
something like flip a bit we want to see
what happens we do the random mutation
well one thing that we could do is we
could do an index operation and then
just X or it with a true value because
as we remember X touring with the true
value has the has the property of making
a false into a true and true into a
false and so here you can see this
chromosome had its single bit flipped at
this position and we can randomly
determine what that position is now one
thing that we might see is that if we
wanted to do that crossover we can't add
an umpire raised in the same way that we
can add Python lists there's a reason
for this Python lists our collections so
it makes sense to be able to combine
collections by using some some
concatenation operator which happens to
be the same as the addition operator
however numpy and D arrays are vectors
it doesn't really make sense to append
vectors it's not something that we do
that often it's not a completely unusual
operation but it's not something that we
do and so you can see what I try and do
the crossover and the same style that I
do it in Python it just tells me these
two vectors
our of the wrong shape plus doesn't mean
append anymore doesn't mean concatenate
anymore it means element-wise addition
so I need a different approach well the
different approach that I could do is I
could create an mtm and dra and I could
just use the slice assigning to assign
it a mtng array and so you can see here
I the position for where the cross over
a curse I created an empty and dra and
then I just performed assignments in
order to perform the crossover now in
order to actually do my simulation I
need to have a dictionary representing
all of the populations for that
simulation I need to pick the mates
figure out how many children they have
breed them what I breed them I need to
perform crossover and random mutation
but one interesting thing that we know
is that each population is the same size
the previous population so we can use
that information in order to do another
dimensionality trick where instead of
having a 2d numpy array where each row
represents the chromosome and each
column represents a bit in that
chromosome we could make it a three
dimensional numpy in the array where
that additional dimension represents
each stage in our simulation so that's
one more dimension that represents the
simulation evolving over time now one
thing that we can do with numpy is we
can do some of our slicing tricks are
fancy indexing so here you can see we
can select single bits out of this this
is saying select every row select every
chromosome and just select the bits from
three to six and that chromosome one
thing that we owe let's see that one
doesn't work so one thing that we can
then do is we could think well we could
maybe try to sort these chromosomes on a
specific axis in order to determine we
wanted to we want to determine heroes
you want to determine what the indices
are and so here if we had what we want
to do is you want to take these
populations and we want to figure out
what are the mothers and what are the
Fathers what are the two sides of that
meeting what we could do to represent
the crossover is as follows we could
perform this as a matrix operation we
could take all of them all the parents
on one side and all the parents on the
other side we could determine
random index so I wish to sell had run
but this cell just randomly determines
that index for where the crossover occur
actually randomly determines multiple
indices we can determine all the indices
at once so what this cell does is it
randomly determines where the crossover
will occur for every individual
chromosome we can use that and a little
bit of matrix multiplication in order to
perform the crossover and so you can see
here we're actually creating an a mask
which has one's up to a certain point
and zeros at the end and zeroes up to a
certain point and ones at the end we can
negate that mask in order to flip it and
we can just take element wise all of the
parents on one size multiply times a
mask plus all the parents on the other
side multiplied times the inverse of the
mask add them together and as an
aggregate operation perform the mating
like that and so you can see one thing
that we can do with numpy is we can do
other fancy indexing like we can select
the first the second and the third
chromosome all at once what we might
want to do is select the number of
couples so we want to figure out how
many couples we have and here you can
see I randomly generated all the couples
so this says ten couples two and six
will mate one will mate with itself
seven and two will mate three will mate
with itself three and seven will mate
and what i can do is i can use my little
trick here to randomly select what the
populations look like where the mates
are then perform my little crossover
trick to cross them all over and you can
see there's no explicit looping here in
Python we had at least two or three
levels of explicit looping at numpy we
just use a fairly simple matrix
multiplication trick and some masking
tricks what this requires is that we
think in terms of matrices and we think
in terms of bit operations now what we
need to do is we need to mutate these
and mutating them all at once is a
little bit tricky so what we'll do is
we'll if we thought there's a mutation
rate of one and we randomly selected
where that mutation would be by doing a
numpy choice with a specific size here
you could see this says mutate only the
last bit this says mutate none of these
bits and this would have mutating of the
first two bits the problem is this
approach won't account for a bit being
flipped multiple times in a row in the
previous code I
gave the chromosome 5 10 20 or 50
chances sorry 5 10 15 or 20 chances in
order to have a bit flip and so some of
those fits could have been flipped and
then flipped back with this approach if
I try and generate a true false value at
the same shape of the population to
represent where the bit flips are and I
then I won't have the possibility that
if it could be flipped a certain number
of times so I have to do something a
little bit more clever what I know is
that a numpy I can create an empty array
containing all zeros and I know I can
create an index and I can select out of
that index or I can use the assignment
to assign into that index using a
specific value so here assigning with a
numpy array allows me to assign the
value 1 to all the positions that are
specified here so this puts a 1 into all
these positions so what I could do is I
could generate a zeros array of two
dimension and I could say well I want to
set the first in a second row but that's
not quite what I want to do what I want
to do is I want to generate an array
that represents all the random flips and
then actually do that flipping and this
isn't quite what I want instead what I
could use is numpy not put I can create
a array of zeros for buy four select the
first and the second value in this
flattened array and put a one into those
two places now you're being to see how
this can be built up because what I'll
do is I'll create a red i'll create a
random array with values from 0 to 4
i'll take those and I'll scale them up
so that those so that those values now
represent offsets in my flattened array
and so here you can see these are
offsets in my flattened array and then
what I'll do is I'll put ones at all
those offsets what you can think is I
can perform all my bit flipping at once
by selecting all of the bits in the
flattened array where they'll be flips
and I can perform all a bit something at
once using a single call to numb pied
output so here's what this looks like
for the entire population here's the
bits that I chose for each of my
populations
here are the indices for the bit flips
are going to occur here's the scaling of
those two flattened indices because even
though I look this is a two-dimensional
structure in numpy this is just a block
of memory so these are the actual memory
offsets or rather here are the actual
memory offsets these are the actual
places where I'm going to do the fit
flipping and then what i can do is i can
put a one so here you can see i
represent the entire flipping of all the
bits for the entire population all at
once and I can repeat that a certain
number of times and one really neat
thing that I can do is if I represent
the flips so here you can see here all
the bits lips I'm going to do for my
population I can actually do all the
flips by doing a single XOR operation
and so I end up with some code that
looks like this this represents the
entire process of breeding these what I
do is I create my random population I
select my mates I figure out which of
the which are the parents on one side
which of the parents either side I
perform my cross over like this I create
a mask and then create offsets from
those masks I flatten the array to
create those offsets and then I put a
one to represent all the bit flipping
that represents one one study of bit
flipping and then i create the
probabilities and what i can do that's
very interesting is I can perform
multiple bit flipping simultaneously
previously for a chromosome of size five
I could flip it I would I would allow it
to do it up to five bit flips I can
actually perform all of those
simultaneously by taking each of the
arrays that I had for those bit flips
and exhorting them together because you
can think if I said flip here and I said
flip again that's the same thing as not
doing a flip at all so I can remove even
one more layer of looping by performing
in aggregate all of the bit flips all at
once with a single matrix with a single
matrix operation or single numpy
operation so with that I want to show
you all the code put together because
I'm running out of time here you can see
I have number of steps my population
size my number of couples they're going
to be chosen the number of mutations
that they might have my mutation rate
and here i have my simulation i will
still use a pure python structure
because the different matrices that
different higher or higher dimensional
matrices representing each of my
simulation
for the size of the chromosomes are not
same sized I can't put them into one big
numpy array so I still use a Python
dictionary keyed on the length of the
chromosome where each of the elements of
that chromosome is a list where each of
those lists represent one one step in
the evolution of this population and
then what i do is i compute the mask for
where the bits lips will occur i take my
last population i choose the mating
pairs i compute the crossover indices i
perform all the bit flip simultaneously
at once i actually rather i compute
where the bit flips would be then i
generate the probabilities for all the
for all the bit flips and then i perform
in one step here at the bottom the
crossover and the flipping
simultaneously using a single using a
single expression which itself
internally implements all the looping
that I had to do externally in Python
and what you can see is it takes one
second and if I can scroll down the
results are right here does the results
and those are the results that I expect
I see convergence towards perfect
perfect fitness and you can see this
took one second to run my previous
example took two seconds to run but one
thing I didn't highlight for you is this
population size is 10 times this big so
this is actually an order of magnitude
faster than my last simulation so that's
numpy approach I'm pretty much out of
time but I wanted to show you a design
exercise for how you take a problem how
you'd solve it in pure python and then
how you'd flip on your head you're
thinking in order to design this in a
numpy approach I hope that you
appreciated that it's been my pleasure
speaking at this event thank you so much